Speaker 1: I want to just briefly play for
you a clip of what might be.
And then I think we're going to be done with
vaccine stuff for today.
These may be one of the most ignorant and
dangerous anti vaccine comments that we've
seen through this entire cycle.
And it's the idea of a vaccine simply being
an unnatural thing.
It's an unnatural thing.
And by definition, maybe it would be bad.
This is a guy named Rob Schmidt who's on Newsmax.
Rob Schmidt made these comments not too long
ago, about five days ago.
I just missed it at the time.
Listen to what he says about vaccination in
this clip.
Speaker 2: You know, I've one thing I've always
thought, and maybe you can guide me on this,
because obviously I'm not a doctor, but I've
always thought
Speaker 1: glad to clarify that
Speaker 2: about vaccines.
And I always think about just nature and the
way everything works.
And I feel like a vaccination in a weird way
is just generally kind of going against nature.
Like I mean, if there is some disease out
there, maybe there's just an ebb and flow
to life where something supposed to wipe out
a certain amount of people.
And that's just kind of the way evolution
goes.
Vaccines kind of stand in the
Speaker 1: way of that.
This is so painfully stupid.
I mean, it's painfully stupid in a number
of different ways.
First of all, what does it mean to be for
or against nature?
I mean, that vaccines are made in the natural
world.
They don't exist spontaneously and often when
you when people make arguments about nature,
sometimes they're just wrong about what exists
spontaneously in the natural world.
They sort of say, well, that's created by
society.
A good, good example of that is one of the
big anti-gay arguments for a while was it's
not natural.
Homosexuality is not natural because it doesn't
lead to reproduction.
You can't you know, a gay couple or a lesbian
couple can't only by virtue of their genitalia
and reproductive systems create offspring.
But then you look at the natural world and
you see, oh, there's hundreds or even thousands
of.
Each species in which homosexuality has been
identified.
So what does it really mean to say it's unnatural?
And so we kind of realize that it's they'll
just use the word if they think it favors
their argument.
Now, here, he sort of means to say something
else, which is vaccination doesn't exist in
nature spontaneously.
If you understand about poison, you would
know that a really long time ago.
I don't know if it's eight hundred years ago,
a thousand or more people started to figure
out you could start to get maybe not quite
eight hundred.
I don't want to misspeak.
Maybe it was more like five hundred years
ago.
You could start ingesting very small amounts
of poison that would be deadly in larger quantities
to develop an immunity.
Is that unnatural, by the way?
Rob Schmitt is is talking about it because
you're taking the poison which exists and
just using a little bit of it, a little bit
more to build up a tolerance.
So anyway, it's a meaningless point.
Let's listen to a little bit more of it.
Speaker 2: Do you follow what I'm saying?
Does that make sense to somebody in medicine?
Well, there are some reports of support, what
you're saying, there's one by Nielsen and
colleagues from Boston and the Mayo Clinic
that shows among vaccinated populations the
diversity of different strains is narrowing.
So it's going to be a numbers of strains right
now in the United States, where about 40 percent
of UK variants with the alpha variant and
we're about 30 percent now Delta, which is
the India, that they get progressively weaker.
But the diversity is changing with vaccination.
And I think probably the best way to think
about it is vaccines really ought to be targeted
to protect the highest risk individuals.
Speaker 1: OK, anyway, so this guy is sort
of playing a little bit coy with some of this
stuff.
But the point here is when you say it's not
natural, is correction of myopia via contact
lenses or glasses natural in the sense that
do contact lenses exist in the real world?
Is surgery that extends life for conditions
that would have many, many previous times
killed people?
Is that natural?
Is the idea that because something doesn't
spontaneously exist without human intervention,
it would somehow be bad is a painfully dumb
idea.
And unfortunately, the audience that's watching
this stuff is exactly the type of audience
that would be likely to fall for it.
So just horrifying stuff on Newsmax and an
argument that's not really an argument one
way or the other.
We're going to have more examples of stuff
like this on our Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show.
And when you're there, you can follow me on
Instagram as well at David Pakman or both
or neither, whatever is your pleasure.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this